welcome to taking control of your
personal data in my 20 years as a
computer scientist and researcher i've
watched the landscape of data collection
and analysis change many times over
sometimes in ways we've expected and
sometimes in ways that surprise us
never before in human history have we
been able to share so much about
ourselves with other people so quickly
and never in our history have we been so
exposed to forces that want to take
advantage of that ability in this course
we'll explore the pros and cons of this
new reality i'll expose the hidden
truths about how our data is harvested
and used and i'll dispel some of the
myths about privacy that can get in the
way of clear decision making when it
comes to your personal data
most of all my intention is to empower
you
through knowledge through careful
thought and through curated strategies
to help you achieve your privacy goals
so let's get started
our data tells stories it's bad at
keeping secrets
artificial intelligence can bring those
secrets out sometimes for good and
sometimes in very creepy ways
if you're taking this course i imagine
you might have a pretty suspicious view
of how your personal data is used
and in a lot of ways you'd be right
but personal data can also be a powerful
tool to help people
consider this example
suicides among soldiers especially those
returning from conflict zones is
unacceptably high
the department of defense acknowledges
this as one of their most frustrating
problems that they want to do more to
address
one project showed how soldiers social
media data and other writings could be
analyzed by artificial intelligence and
used to identify people at risk of
self-harm the resulting tools could
identify suicidality more accurately
than state-of-the-art medical approaches
and these were built into other tools to
help medical professionals intervene
it's a great story of how this
technology can be helpful in profound
ways
but as you might suspect that same
analysis can also be used to hurt people
one infamous story comes from canada
there a woman was diagnosed with severe
depression and put on long-term sick
leave
her doctors and employer all agreed that
this was the best course of action
her doctors advised her to have fun and
maybe take a vacation
when she did she posted a photo of
herself at the beach on facebook
the insurance company paying for her
disability saw the photos decided that
she looked like she was having a good
time and thus was no longer depressed
and revoked her coverage
apparently no one told the insurer that
even severely depressed people can smile
and laugh sometimes
we all know that when we post things
online whether it's a review or a social
media post this personal information can
be seen and shared
later in the course we'll dive into just
how much data is out there
but data is collected in lots of
startling ways and new information is
created from that with artificial
intelligence
in this opening lecture we're going to
get an overview of just how that's
happening so you can go into things
knowing just how much is known about you
it'll probably include a lot of things
you don't expect
you create a lot of data just existing
in a digital world your purchases are
tracked through your use of credit cards
and loyalty cards your internet traffic
and web searches are recorded your
social media posts contain all sorts of
personal information
your phone tracks your location the apps
you use the time of day you're using
them and connects that up with your
contacts your calendars your phone calls
and your text messages
cameras capture your movements in public
spaces
it can be a little overwhelming when you
list it all out like that but most of us
probably aren't surprised by any of this
but data's collected in a lot of more
subtle and some may say nefarious ways
consider a patent filed by facebook
they're interested in finding people who
know each other
let's say you and i are at an event
a third person takes a picture of you
outside before you go to the event and
sends it to you
then they later take a picture of me
maybe having a snack later in the
evening and they send it to me
if they're good pictures we may each
post the photo of ourselves on facebook
we're each pictured solo so there are no
other people to tag
we're in different places around the
venue and the pictures were taken at
different times
but facebook thinks that if two people
are at an event and if they were
photographed by the same person they may
know each other
how can they discover that from these
two photos that may have no location
data no time data no reference to the
photographer
they analyze the patterns of dust and
lens scratches hidden in the photo and
can use that to find out that the
pictures were taken by the same camera
at approximately the same time
then they can link us through the photos
taken by that third person and
potentially suggest that we become
friends
or there's the story of the man who used
a cpap machine
this is a breathing machine used by
people with sleep apnea to keep them
breathing
a technician installed a wireless card
in the machine so the patient could have
it checked and updated remotely
but that wireless card was without the
patient's knowledge sending information
about his usage to his doctor and the
company that made the machine
that company was sharing it with the
patient's insurance company
the insurance company was monitoring it
and when they felt that he wasn't using
it the prescribed number of hours they
refused to cover his replacement
supplies
basically they were digitally spying on
him and using that information to deny
him health care
or maybe you've had the experience where
you're chatting with a friend in person
not using your phone at all and you may
say next year for spring break we might
go to costa rica you don't look up
anything about costa rica or post about
it you only make the comment to your
friend yet the next day ads for costa
rican tourism start appearing on
facebook or blogs or other websites
how does that happen
some apps have code that turns on your
phone's microphone and passively listens
in
we'll delve a lot deeper into data
collection later in the course but
suffice it to say that huge amounts of
data are being collected about you and
you're probably unaware of many of them
why is so much collected
because it can be used to generate even
more information about you
you're probably familiar with artificial
intelligence algorithms that use your
data even if you haven't thought about
it
for example netflix and amazon both make
recommendations to users
netflix suggests shows we might want to
watch
amazon recommends products we might want
to buy
they do this with artificial
intelligence algorithms that analyze
what we've interacted with before and
then guess about new things we might
like in the future
but what's going on inside those
algorithms and what else can they find
out about us let's start with some
fundamentals
an algorithm is just a series of steps a
computer takes
artificial intelligence or ai algorithms
are steps a computer takes to become
intelligent about something that may be
siri understanding what you're asking a
map application finding a good route for
you to take or netflix recommending a
show you want to watch
we'll mostly be talking about machine
learning algorithms a specific kind of
artificial intelligence algorithm that
helps a computer learn things
as a simple example of how these
algorithms work say you have an app that
tracks when you go outside for a walk or
a run
it also knows the weather
if that app had a machine learning
algorithm built in it could start to
learn which weather conditions are
conducive to your walks
each day it would note the conditions
and then wait to see if you go outside
if you do it learns that day's
conditions are good if you don't it
learns that they're bad
over time it builds up a model of your
preferences
we build up mental models like this for
ourselves and others all the time
if you walk with a friend you probably
know what days they'll want to come out
and what days they want to stay home
that's because you have learned a model
of their behavior and even if you've
never seen a day with this exact set of
conditions you can still make a good
guess
machine learning models do the same
thing
the algorithm takes some input like
weather conditions and an answer about
whether it's a good or bad day
then the algorithm builds up a model
from a series of examples
when it's done you can ask it a question
about a totally new set of weather
conditions and it can make a guess about
whether it's a good or bad day now
that's a really basic example to give
you an idea of how these algorithms work
the examples we'll talk about in this
lesson use your personal data as input
instead of weather conditions
they use that data to build up models
that let them guess all kinds of
personal things about you
let's take a look at some of these
in my lab at the university of maryland
we did one of the first research
projects in this space
we wanted to take people's public
facebook information and use it to guess
what their personality traits were
you may have taken a basic personality
test like the myers-briggs test
that's the one that gives you a profile
like intj
these tests measure things like whether
you're an introvert or an extrovert if
you're a procrastinator or a planner and
list maker and if you're open to new
experiences or prefer to do the same
thing to make an algorithm that could
guess these traits from facebook data we
had hundreds of people take a
personality test and then fed a machine
learning algorithm their facebook data
and their scores
the algorithm learned a model of each
personality trait
in the end the algorithm could guess
someone's score on the personality test
exceptionally well
just by examining their facebook data
it was only off by about 10
which is basically how much your score
can change when you take a test
depending on the mood you're in
so even though you don't announce on
facebook that you're an extrovert or a
procrastinator the algorithm can tell
since that first study back in 2012
there's been an explosion of work on
this topic
one of my favorite studies was done at
cambridge university
they wanted to see if they could use
facebook likes to predict a whole host
of personal attributes
so let's talk about the input
on facebook you can like all sorts of
things sports teams movies books bands
restaurants or any page that a person
creates
the things a person likes is a pretty
narrow sliver of all the information
they share on facebook but the
interesting thing about it is that it's
always public
you can't make your likes private so
anyone can get access to them at any
time
if we can use those public likes to
discover private information about
people that's pretty interesting
and that's what these cambridge
researchers did
they used the likes to predict
demographic information like race
religion
gender sexual orientation behavioral
things like if you were a drinker smoker
or drug user they could identify
preferences like if you were liberal or
conservative
they could even tell if your parents
divorced before you were 21.
now you may be thinking that you don't
need any algorithms to connect likes to
some of these attributes
if i like the gop page on facebook
there's a good chance i'm conservative
if i like the jim beam page there's a
good chance i'm a drinker but it turns
out that algorithms don't rely on these
obvious indicators very often
instead they're finding statistical
connections that don't make a lot of
sense to us humans
in the article they wrote about their
work these researchers gave an example
they were able to predict the score
someone would get on an iq test from
their likes
the researchers listed the four likes
that were most indicative of high
intelligence
in no particular order they were science
which maybe makes sense smart people
like science
thunderstorms
the tv show the colbert rapport
and curly fries
now curly fries are delicious but
they're loved by many
how do they show up is one of the
strongest indicators of a high
intelligence test score
the real answer is that we don't know
these algorithms are very opaque
they can give us an accurate answer a
lot of the time but they don't give us
any insight into how it got that answer
part of that is intentional
computer science as a field is only
concerned with whether something can be
computed it's not interested in the
social insights as to why
but i can give you an idea of what's
going on behind the scenes
if you think about it most of what you
like on social media is social
it's stories pages pictures and videos
that appear in front of you because
someone shared it
rarely is it something you go out and
search for yourself
so what we see depends on our friends
sociologists have known for a long time
that we're friends with people who are
similar to ourselves
they call this homophily and it's
basically the birds of a feather flock
together concept
if you're white your friends tend to be
white if you're rich your friends tend
to be rich if you graduated from college
your friends also probably graduated
from college
it's not that all of your friends are
the same as you but rather that your
personal attributes are shared by your
friends more often than they're shared
by the general population
the second thing to know about here is
how things spread on social media
we know from research that viral videos
fads rumors fake news and pages to like
on facebook all spread in online social
networks the same way that diseases
spread in offline social networks we can
take models from the cdc that explain
the spread of the flu
and put them on top of the facebook
network and see exactly how a viral post
will spread
so to put that together imagine we have
someone smart who also happens to like
curly fries she makes a page for them
likes it and then her friends see it
some of them might also like curly fries
and then like the page and it spreads to
their friends now homophily tells us
that since the creator was smart her
friends are probably smart and their
friends are probably also smart
so you get the curly fries page
spreading like a virus through this
smart part of facebook
and in the end when you come along and
like the page the algorithm doesn't know
what curly fries are or iq tests are it
just knows that you did a thing that
other high scoring people did so you
deserve a high score too
essentially the algorithm guesses you
belong to the group of people who liked
this page and their traits are reflected
back onto you
without knowing it the algorithm is
picking up on traces of our social
interactions and using them to learn
more about us
homophily is incredibly powerful when
used by these algorithms and in future
lectures we'll talk about how it can be
used to automatically profile people
even if they have no online presence at
all
and it's not just social media that
allows this to happen
the new york times shared a fascinating
story about these algorithms at work in
the retail space
it starts with a dad in minnesota who
goes into his local target he goes up to
the manager with a target flyer that was
mailed to his daughter
the dad is in a rage you sent this to my
15 year old daughter it's just coupons
for maternity clothes and baby bottles
and diapers she's only a junior in high
school do you want her to get pregnant
and the manager has no idea what he's
talking about because the stores don't
send those flyers out but he promises to
look into it
a couple weeks later the manager calls
the dad back to apologize and the dad
says actually i owe you an apology
because it turns out my 15 year old is
pregnant but target found out before she
told us
how does this happen
well it turns out that target computes
what they call a pregnancy score for all
their female customers and not only can
it tell if you're pregnant it can also
tell your due date
target isn't using social media to do
this
the personal data they have is purchase
histories
if you use a loyalty card or even if you
use credit or debit cards it's pretty
easy for a company to piece that
together into a lifetime history of
everything you've ever bought from them
lots of people shop at target so they
have millions of people's lifetime
purchase histories
target cares about pregnancy because
there are only two main times that
people change their shopping habits when
they move and when they have a baby
if target can find out when women are
pregnant and get them to come into the
store once they can plant the seed that
it might be a good place to shop once
they have their baby
but how do they know someone's pregnant
well it's very easy to tell when someone
had a baby based on their purchase
history the day that first baby is born
they suddenly start buying tons of
things they never bought before diapers
wipes maybe formula
so target can go through their huge set
of data
find all the people who had babies and
look at what they were buying seven or
eight months before that
what purchases tell us a woman is early
in her pregnancy
you might guess a pregnancy test or
vitamins but it turns out it's not any
individual thing
it's combinations of things
one example that was reported is this
if a woman buys an extra bottle of
lotion
a purse that's big enough to double as a
diaper bag but not a proper diaper bag
just a big purse
and brightly colored rugs
so imagine you're in line and the woman
in front of you has cocoa butter a big
handbag and a blue rug and you whisper
to yourself she's totally pregnant
why these things
some make sense but the rug really
doesn't you're not building a nursery
that early in a pregnancy
so why is it predictive
again the artificial intelligence
doesn't tell us why
what the algorithms are doing is finding
statistical connections that subtly
indicate differences between the two
groups
they're not necessarily logical and they
don't apply to everyone
but for the algorithms they can find
many small statistical indicators that
help it guess correctly even if it
doesn't make sense to us humans
it's really important to know that these
are not meaningful correlations in the
data from a human perspective
there are statistical patterns found for
some people in the context of millions
of others that allow a mathematical tool
to separate people into groups
that can be frustrating for people who
want insight because they don't get it
but it also has important implications
for us as consumers
the major thing these examples show us
is that you can't hide from these
algorithms
we may be able to control what we post
on social media or what we buy but we
don't know what our actions say to an
algorithm
you wouldn't know that liking curly
fries would say anything about your
intelligence or that buying things that
aren't about pregnancy specifically
would reveal it
so if there is something you want to
keep private there's no way to know how
to do that when an algorithm is doing
the analysis
also these correlations are not stable
curly fries may no longer say anything
about intelligence
this doesn't matter to the algorithms
they constantly refine and rebuild their
models and don't rely on these
correlations explicitly
for users it means that you can't adjust
your actions based on knowledge about
what was predictive last week because it
may have
changed all of the examples we've
discussed so far are algorithms that
discover things that are true about you
right now
are you an introvert are you pregnant
what's your iq score
but researchers are getting very good at
predicting things that will be true
about you in the future even before you
know it
researchers at cornell weren't looking
at predicting future behavior
instead they wanted to be able to look
at your list of friends and pick out
which person was your spouse or
significant other
to do that they only looked at your list
of friends and which of them knew each
other
they didn't include any personal
information just here are your friends
say we number them one through two
hundred and for each of them which of
your other friends did they know
so maybe friend number one is also
friends with number 27 53 89 and so on
one easy guess about who might be your
significant other is the person who has
the most friends in common with you
basically that friend who's connected to
the greatest number of your other
friends
that's a pretty good guess
but researchers are looking for more
than just good guesses so they came up
with this measure called social
dispersion
at its heart
social dispersion is a natural concept
if you think about your social life
whether it's online or offline you tend
to have pretty distinct social circles
you have friends you grew up with maybe
friends you went to school with
people who do activities with you like
members of your church or sports team
family members
these distinctions are especially clear
for me because i've tended to move every
time i do something different in my life
i grew up in a small town in northern
illinois and i have my high school
friends i come from a big catholic
family and have a whole bunch of cousins
who i'm friends with on facebook
and even though they come from the same
town they aren't friends with my high
school friends because most of them went
to the catholic school
so the only overlap between these groups
are my brother and sister-in-law who
went to high school with me and who
obviously also know the family
then i moved for undergrad and i have
friends there and then i moved again for
graduate school and i have a group of
professional friends
i play ice hockey on a men's team so
there's a group of like 20 guys off in
the corner who are all friends with each
other and who don't know anyone else and
that's fine social dispersion says that
our spouse or significant other is the
person who's connected to the greatest
number of these different social groups
even if they don't have a lot of friends
in common with us
and this also works out for me so i've
only been married a few years my husband
is german and only became a naturalized
citizen a couple years ago
he grew up all over the world not with
me he's nine years older than i am he's
a lawyer he went to different schools
and so we actually have very few friends
in common but he's connected to every
single one of those social groups i
mentioned
he met some family members at a wedding
the high school friend who came into
town for a visit work friends at a
reception and so on
so this is an interesting thing that you
can predict about someone and it
performs remarkably well
researchers found that it's right about
75 of the time which is really
impressive when you're picking from a
list of hundreds of facebook friends
but the people who came up with this
wanted to do better so after they did
that first analysis they thought well
maybe they could collect some additional
data and improve their method
what they found was when they
recollected the data two months later if
they had guessed wrong for you in the
first place you were 50 percent more
likely to have broken up in the
intervening two months than if they had
guessed right
so essentially they were able to build
an algorithm that can tell if your
relationship is going to last while
you're in it and you think everything's
going fine
they didn't mention this in the paper
but they can also tell you who a good
alternative is to your current partner
they could say well it doesn't look like
it's going to work out with bob but
frank over here might be a good choice
other research has specifically set out
to try to predict people's futures
one project followed pregnant women on
twitter and developed a model that could
predict whether they would develop
postpartum depression
on the day a woman gives birth the
algorithm already knows the outcome and
it's right 80 to 85 percent of the time
it does this using data about the style
of people's writings their interactions
and the kind of posts they make in my
lab we were interested in understanding
alcoholism
we looked for people who posted on
twitter that they were attending their
first alcoholics anonymous meeting and
followed their posts after that to see
if 90 days later they were sober or
drinking again
we made sure they explicitly said
it could be a year later they celebrated
one year of sobriety so we knew they
were also sober at 90 days out
it could be that two weeks later they
were complaining about being hungover so
we knew they were drinking
once we had this information we
collected everything they posted up
until the moment they announced they
were going to aa
then we built a model that would analyze
their posts and behavior
at the moment they decided to seek help
our algorithm could predict whether that
help would work and it's right 85
percent of the time
i'm still not sure if this was a good
idea
our algorithm does offer some insight
into how it came up with the answer
it can alert a user that their
difficulties in dealing with stress or
their social circles are indicators that
they may have difficulty in recovery
but it also is deeply personal and could
be used in ways that are unfair
how can you take control over these
algorithms
in most ways you can't
in the u.s you do not own your personal
data and companies do not have to tell
you what they know about you nor how
they're using your data
these algorithms are used behind the
scenes all the time often without our
knowledge sometimes it's for relatively
benign purposes like showing us the most
relevant ad
sometimes it's really helpful like
amazon telling us the items we need to
go with a new appliance we bought
but they were also used in the 2016
presidential election to try to suppress
and manipulate the vote and no one told
us about it until after the fact
i ethically struggle as someone doing
this work
there are great ways this technology
helps people every day but there are
also really terrible uses of it that
invade people's privacy and that impact
their lives
i used to describe my feelings as
similar to how it must have felt working
on the manhattan project building
nuclear technology
you can see the good and tremendously
bad consequences
i used to feel this was a bit hyperbolic
10 years ago but now i feel like the
dystopian path we're heading down shows
that it's a pretty apt metaphor
i don't have all the solutions to the
dilemmas that arise here either but i do
think that understanding the full
picture of how personal data is
collected manipulated and used is a good
first step
and when i think there are important
legal or regulatory solutions i'll point
them out
certainly many things are going to have
to change for the world to remain fair
and just in the face of the power that
comes with big data and ai in future
lectures we'll also talk about steps you
can take to gain more control over your
digital life it'll be scary but it won't
all be scary and my hope is that you
finish this course feeling empowered and
more aware because this really is an
area where knowledge is power
we'll encounter many limits to our
control during this course but the one
limit we can truly combat on our own is
ignorance
join me for the next lecture where we'll
talk in depth about what personal data
is and how it's gathered
[Music]
you